sie fühlen sich alleinelassen ihre Bosse
in der Autoindustrie streichen Millionen
Gehälter ein die Branche boomt aber
Tracy und ihre Tochter Bailey haben
nichts davon sie hoffen dass Joe Biden
der an diesem Tag nach Detroit kommt
hört was die Streikenden zu sagen
haben ich habe gerade mal
129 mehr als vor 25 Jahren als ich
anfing etwas mehr das steht in keinem
Verhältnis e
unterstü hoffentlich bekommen wir die
Erhöhung etwas
[Musik]
schneller jeder hier will sich die Autos
die wir verkaufen selbst leisten können
so einfach ist
das glauben sie dass beiden die
Verhandlungen voranbringen
wird die ganze Presse der ganze Auftrieb
weil er hierherkmt das erzeugt Druck auf
die
fabrikidens Kritiker sehen das hier als
Verzweiflungstat weil seinefr gewrte
doch so schlecht sind nein sagen seine
Freunde das ist der echte Joe ein Mann
des Volkes diesem Fall der Arbeiter 40%
mehr Lohn fordern sie weil sich die
Bosse der Autoindustrie Hundertfache
Steigerungen gönnten das ein Präsident
sich einfach mal dazu stellt sich auf
ihre Seite schlägt hat es in Amerika
noch nie gegeben aber Joe Biden braucht
die Gewerkschaften für seine
Wiederwahl ihr habt Opfer gebracht als
die Konzerne in Schwierigkeiten waren
jetzt geht es ihnen unglaublich gut
deshalb sollte es auch euch unglaublich
gut
gehen natürlich wissen alle dass er den
Konzernen keine höheren Löhne diktieren
kann aber ihnen nützt die Aufmerksamkeit
und ihm der gute Eindruck denn vieles
läuft für den Präsidenten derzeit gar
nicht gut ausgerechnet Sohn hunterbeiden
schadet Vater Joe erheblich durch sein
Strafverfahren weil er über den Besitz
seiner Waffe gelogen hat und durch die
Ermittlungen gegen ihn wegen
zwielichtiger
Geschäftsbeziehungen kaum ein Termin bei
dem er nicht gefragt wird ob er in
hunterers Deals in der Ukraine und in
China involviert war seine Berater
schütteln jedes Mal den Kopf wenn er
seinen Vater stolz trotz sich immer
wieder kund
tut ich bin sehr stolz auf meinen Sohn
dass er ihn bei offiziellen Terminen
häfig mitnimmt versteht keiner mehr denn
er befeuert damit den Verdacht dass
Hunter seine früheren Geschäfte eng mit
ihm abgesprochen hat die Beweislage
dafür ist äußerst dünn aber dick genug
dass die Republikaner im Wahlkampf nun
das Gleiche wollen wie eins die
Demokraten gegen Donald
Trump diese Vorwürfe von Machtmissbrauch
Strafvereitlung Korruption müssen
untersucht werden deshalb habe ich einen
Ausschuss angewiesen ein formelles
amtsenthebungsprüfverfahren zu starten
gegen Präsident Joe
Biden parallel dazu sorgen extreme
Republikaner im Haushaltsstreit wohl für
einen shutdown aller Bundesbehörden sie
wollen beiden damit schaden dabei ist
das der wirklich wundepunkt des
Präsidenten an der Grenze zu Mexiko
spitz sich die Lage weiter zu im August
wurden
330.000 illegale Einwanderer auf griffen
derzeit kommen täglich bis zu 11000 neue
dazu beidens strenge Maßnahmen von Juni
Asylantrag nur noch per App wer illegal
kommt hat 5 Jahre lang kein Antragsrecht
alles wirkungslos selbst demokratische
Bürgermeister rufen den Notstand
[Musik]
aus wir müssen etwas unternehmenes unter
Kontrolle bringen das ist nicht normal
es ist nicht normal dass Menschen über
die Grenze kommen ohne Konsequenz
die Bilder schüren Zweifel an der
Handlungsfähigkeit des Präsidenten dass
beiden diese Woche in Arizona Wahlkampf
macht aber nicht zur Grenze kommt ärgert
viele und dann ist da noch sein
Alter 77% der Amerikaner finden der
80-Jährige ist zu alt für eine zweite
Amtszeit und doch geschah hier in
Chicago letzte Woche ein Wunder von dem
es keine Bilder gibt beim Dinner unter
freiem Himmel Schaten sich die 100
wichtigsten Spender der Demokratischen
Partei um Joe Biden und carela Harris
über das Alter des Präsidenten wurde
gewitzelt eine kämpferische Präsentation
seines wahlkampfteams
bejubelt die beiden sollen zum Angriff
übergehen ihre Erfolge klar Maen prompt
tut er das bei dieser
Wahlkampfveranstaltung am
Samstag wer erfolgreich ist muss
weitermachen unser Plan funktioniert meh
1h Millionen neue Jobs seit Amtsantritt
mehr als jeder Präsident vorher in einer
Amtszeit es ist keine leere pralerei wie
man hier in Louisiana bestaunen kann
Menschen haben wieder Arbeit sogar
besser bezahlte als zuvor in der
Werftindustrie made in America dieses
Schiff trägt zum Kampf des Landes gegen
den Klimawandel bei denn die offshore
Windräder gefördert aus beidens
Klimapaket müssen gewartet werden die
Mechaniker und Ingenieure brauchen
solche Spezialschiffe mit denen sie
wochenlang unterwegs sein können der
Schiffsbau lange im Niedergang boomt
wieder und das ist erst der
Anfang derzeit sind 30 Schiffe im Bau
für die Windparks wir brauchen aber 50
bis 60
weitere Amerikas Industriebasis im
Aufschwung bei Wind und Sonnenenergie
der Halbleitertechnik
Elektroautos und
Schiffen auch beidens Bündnispolitik
gilt als höchst erfolgreich gerade erst
waren die Anführer der Inselstaaten des
Pazifik zu Gast beiden will Chinas
Einfluss eingrenzen und den von Russland
deshalb war wodomia selenski da vorher
hatte sich der US-Präsident in New York
mit Russlands zentralasiatischen
Nachbarn
getroffen beiden mag zerbrechlich wirken
seinem historischen Besuch im
kommunistischen Vietnam aber die
Schlagzahl seiner diplomatischen
Initiativen ist hoch der Generalsekretär
der Kommunistischen Partei ist übrigens
jünger als der US-Präsident der
hinterher bei der Pressekonferenz
offenerzig
sagt ich weiß nicht wie es euch geht ich
gehe jetzt ins
Bett ja beiden fällt schon mal zum
Schrecken seiner Berat die haben ihm
jetzt tägliche Gleichgewichtsübungen
verordnet er soll häufiger tonchuhe
tragen und wenn er einen starken
Auftritt
hat wollen sie hinterher sicherstellen
dass so
etwas den Eindruck nicht verwessssert
der Präsident sei seinem Amt jederzeit
gewachsen sagen
sie wir brauchen keine Altersgrenze das
ist
lächerlich
schlich S und manche mit 80 die Dinge
hervorragend und effektiv umsetzen ich
weiß was ich sage ist nicht populär
Menschen glauben man sollte alle über 70
loswerden aber das ist falsch jeder
altert
unterschiedlich ich sehe ihn jeden Tag
ich verbringe viel Zeit mit
ihm Themen zu durdenken wie kein anderer
es kann um kluge und wichtige
Entscheidungen für das amerikanische
Volk zu fällen und was dann daraus wird
ich glaube dass das Volk sicher sein
will dass sein Präsident liefert und Joe
Biden
liefert das hoffen Sie auch in Detroit
Michigan natürlich fürchten hier manche
dass sein Plan für den Umstieg Amerikas
auf Elektroautos auch ihre Jobs
gefährdet dann trifft im Getümmel der
alte Herr auf die ganz junge Generation
Josua 13 Jahre
alt toll Joe Biden zu sehen ihm die Hand
zu schütteln meint Josua und seine
Mutter akila sieht beidens
Elektromobilität nicht mehr ganz so
kritisch ich glaube nicht dass er will
dass Elektroautos die Mittelklasse
kaputt machen er will dass wir ein Weg
finden dass jeder einen Platz hat einen
stabilen Job dass die Menschen ihre
Familien ernähren
können und sie hier wollen nächstes Jahr
alle Joe Biden wiederwählen trotz oder
gerade wegen seines
Alters ich mache mir überhaupt keine
Sorgen über sein Alter er hat vor allem
Erfahrung er hat breites Wissen und dann
hat er gute Leute um sich rum um ihm
durch schwierige Zeiten zu helfen ich
mache mir eher Sorgen um andere im
Amt mit anderen ist Donald Trump gemeint
der wird Joe bidens Auftritt hier als
Verzweiflungstat verspotten doch für
viele Wähler hat der alte Präsident
tiefen Eindruck
hinterlassen